greatness
good is the enemy of great jim collins
yesterday i threw out months of work
worked on my team and i spent countless
hours on
agonizing over we created something that
nobody in my industry had done before
we were leading a revolution and before
we created really had a chance to make
an impact
i'm throwing it away because i came up
with something better
something mind-blowing something great
you have to do great work
if you want to make money change
people's lives have a real impact
what you do has to be great and that
often means throwing away
really good ideas to chase greatness
even if you've invested lots of money
time and resources into them
if it's not great it shouldn't be worth
your time
you know when something is great don't
settle
great is scary doing great work is scary
it requires a ton of effort it takes you
to places you've never been before
it means abandoning the safe trusted
path you've known
good is the enemy of great if something
is bad you'll change it
the challenge is when something is good
enough you know it's not great
but it's good enough for people and so
you stop making changes
you stop improving good is worse than
bad because it stops you from achieving
great
being great requires change you don't
just achieve greatness and then stop
the sony walkman might have been great
when it came out but it's not great
anymore
you have to keep pushing boundaries to
stay great
challenge yourself to come up with the
next great push forward
this applies to everything this isn't
just a business idea
it's for every aspect of your life do
you want a great life or a good one
do you want to be in a great
relationship or a good one
stop settling for less when you settle
for less than great you get used to
settling
you settle for the mediocre business you
settle for a mediocre life
you stop chasing your dreams stop
settling and make your business and your
life
great believe